a record-breaking number of Americans
are expected to travel this week for the
4th of July of course 48.9 million
people plan to take a trip for the
holiday according to triple-a that's up
more than four percent from last year
mark Elwood is a contributing editor at
Conde Nast Traveler he's here with how
you can still save still even now on
your summer travel plans mark good
morning
it's a little late but what are there ok
so what are the best apps and websites
to use so I love two things if you're
looking for a hotel last-minute hotel I
swear by hotel tonight
it is a very intuitive beautifully
designed but what I love about it is it
offers deals on a tightly edited
selection of hotels so rather than you
wading through all of them it has picked
kind of the coolest hotels wherever
you're going great great deals you can
book up to a hundred days ahead but you
could book for this week
well what about air flights because I
think normally if you wait this long the
price is going to be higher yes
if you check up if you check a flight
price at the last minute I would know
we've all had that moment of thinking
yeah it costs how much actually holidays
exactly but because of the way the
travel industry works if you see a
flight price that you don't like click
through to the vacations tab on that
airlines website that's where they sell
hotels and flights together because of
how they're priced at the last minute
the package deal
might be cheaper than just the flight
alone even if you don't need the hotel
so you say even booked the flight even
if you're not going to take the hotel
exactly at the cheaper range might work
on everything always worth checking are
there particular destinations where
people can get deals these days I'm
thinking maybe they make a republic but
I wouldn't I wouldn't discourage people
from thinking about the Caribbean in the
summer the rates are very very good I
took there might be a bit of rain off to
lunch but you take it that's what I
think of it so I would also go to London
because remember the UK the pound is
much softer in the exchange rate again
you have dollar and again I'm
recommending London for a reason but I
would tell you you know people perceive
Britain is quite an expensive
destination about 20% cheaper for an
Americans ago now than five years ago
when is air B&B better than a hotel
mark um I always say if your particular
about where you stay so you've got
family you want to be five minutes walk
from Airbnb lets you put a pin in a map
and effectively think I want to stay
right there yeah if you want to be
pampered you want to have that turn to
hunt service you can find some Airbnb
with that service but you want to stay
at a hotel I just think if location is
very very specific Airbnb is great and I
just heard about repo cruises I've never
heard that I had more oh really oh I
love there's a repo cruise repositioning
cruise it doesn't sound promising
so this is what you do want to hear the
words repo we've got a big cruise issue
right now something we're obsessed with
when cruising cruise ships change port
from their winter to summer destinations
they have to sail between them they will
sell you staterooms on those on those
repositioning repos they could be about
40% cheaper a little longer than normal
but boy it's a steal
yeah cuz they got to get there anyway
exactly you can hitch a ride all right
thank you mark always good to see you
did you see you thank you very much